one of the few remaining members of
president Trump's original national
security team says it's time to move on
dan coates says he is resigning as
Director of National Intelligence Coates
had a tense relationship with the
president over some high-profile
security threats including Russia Iran
and North Korea Ben Tracy is at the
White House Ben who is the president
named as Cote successor well the
president says that he's going to
nominate Texas Republican Congressman
John Ratcliffe to replace Dan Coates as
the Director of National Intelligence
and the president made this announcement
via Twitter on Sunday saying that Coates
will leave office on August 15th
now the Director of National
Intelligence serves as the country's top
intelligence official charged with
overseeing all 17 agencies of the US
intelligence community
now Coates has held the role since March
2017 his exit has long been speculated
mainly because he's often clashed with
the president over national security
issues including defending intelligent
agencies conclusion that Russia
interfered in the 2016 election now
Ratcliffe has served in the House since
2015 he's a member of both the
intelligence and Judiciary Committees
the former US Attorney notably defended
President Trump during a fierce exchange
with robert muller during last week's
hearing now Ratcliffe still has to be
confirmed by the Senate and the
president says he will name an Acting
Director in the meantime Tony all right
Ben thank you very much